Okay, for this last question, I'd like you to  prove
that the 4coloring problem is NP-complete,
assuming that it's already known that 3coloring is NP-complete.
And we're going to do that by writing a program that models the reduction proof.
So let's say we're given a magical graph is 4colorable function.
Now, in order to perform this reduction program, we're going to give you
a function graph is 4colorable.
And this function takes as input a graph in the form of an adjacency matrix,
like we've previously discussed, and it returns a boolean--either true or false--
indicating if the input graph is 4colorable in polynomial time.
Now, what I'd like you to do is define a function graph is 3colorable that, again,
takes an adjacency matrix as input and returns a boolean
indicating if the input graph is 3colorable in polynomial time.
Now, as I said, the point of this is to show that the 4coloring problem is NP-complete.
So we'll want you to do a reduction program reducing the graph
that is taken as input to 3colorable and change it into a graph
that is an input to 4colorable to show this reduction.